how does new scientific research get
from here to there let's take a look
behind the scenes
every week the nature receives around
200 online submissions that works out to
more than 10,000 manuscripts submitted
every year and nature's team of in-house
editors carefully considers each paper
they receive the most promising papers
then pass through a rigorous peer review
process where international experts
assess their novelty validity and
significance they often recommend
revisions or additional analysis and the
editors work closely with the scientists
and reviewers to improve the paper
around 8% of submitted papers passed
peer review and are selected by nature's
editors for publication once a paper is
accepted it goes into production where a
lot of things happen to it at once
sub editors make sure that every detail
in the paper is perfect and that the
scientific arguments are made clearly
art directors design and customize the
pictures and graphics for some papers
leading scientists are commissioned to
write additional commentary and analysis
on the research while the multimedia
team records podcasts and shoots videos
and within a few weeks the paper is
finished and ready for the most
important part of its life publication
nature's marketing and press teams
publicizing research and organized press
conferences to announce especially
significant findings the paper is also
published digitally on mobile devices
such as smartphones and tablets and as
always it appears on nature's website
which gets almost 8 million pageviews
per month
but the life of a paper doesn't end
there
nature's focus on high quality research
means that the paper is read by many
other scientists will use the findings
to inspire even more new research
soon enough the original paper gets
cited in new ones
and its life goes on
you